("Hail to the Chief"
by James Sanderson)
- Hello my fellow Americans,
this is my anger
translator, Luther.
- Hi.
- Today is Martin
Luther King, Jr. day.
A day in which we
celebrate a great leader.
- And all y'all do is
remember him one day a year
and then name some
lame ass streets
after him, fuck y'all.
- Now more than ever, it's
important that we remember
his message of peace.
- And I will punch
you in the mouth
if you do not remember
Martin Luther King, Jr.'s
message of peace.
(karate yelling)
- He taught us that one
man can raise awareness
and make social change.
- Because of Martin
Luther King, Jr.
I can walk into any
white man's house
without invitation and
say, "This my house now.
"Get the fuck out."
- Nope, nope, no you can't.
- You cannot do that, Luther.
Stop making shit up, damn!
- I mean, you haven't
done that, right?
- I got to make
some phone calls.